as you do this I didn't get out to
nearly as many films this year as I
would have liked and many of those films
I did see just kind of ran right through
me well so under the shadow was a really
good where the effective horror thriller
a lace crater was an inventive personal
drama with a supernatural twist nuts was
a clever documentary about quack doctors
arrival arrival was another good
personal drama with a supernatural twist
I enjoyed Deadpool and and rogue one
Kubo Zootopia finding dory oh actually
really liked 10 Cloverfield Lane ending
and all so I mean there were a lot of
good films this year there were a lot of
you know nice genre films and some broad
stuff but I mean overall just you know
that is a three syllable word for any
thought too big for little minds my
original plan was to talk about a
cross-section of some of the worst
editing that I saw this year because my
lord
editing is going down the crapper these
days so I lined up a few films to
showcase some of the particular trends
in the way that films are being cut
these days gods of Egypt for its bad
action miss Peregrine's Home for
peculiar children for its poor dialogue
cutting Batman V Superman for it's awful
awful just plot construction but no
Suicide Squad it was just it was it was
shockingly awful that's how I described
Suicide Squad when I came out of the
theater the editing was shockingly awful
in every way
see gods of Egypt has generically
mediocre action and overall flow the
focus in many scenes doesn't really go
anywhere the camera often just floats
around movie
without purpose or intent and there's a
few egregious specific cuts in the movie
miss Peregrine's Home for peculiar
children is a generally enjoyable film
with some charm but it's marred by some
really really bad dialogue editing where
there's no tension or flow to the
dialogue and there's zero breathing room
between scenes it isn't a pervasive
problem but it happens a lot throughout
the movie taken as a whole it's a
problem of over-tightening the film with
a scattering of just bad aimless edits
I'm sorry buddy I know how much you
worship them but there it is Batman V
Superman is its its own can of worms ha
ha the first thing that needs to be
acknowledged about Suicide Squad is its
trouble development the specifics are
hard to nail down because the people who
actually know aren't going to say what
happened because they either need to
play nice for the sake of their careers
or they're contractually restricted from
ever mentioning it but here's what we
know David Ayer had only six weeks to
bash out the script and then shot about
two hundred and thirty hours worth of
footage basically trying to find the
movie in the process of shooting it at
some point Warner Brothers hires trailer
park the team that cut the queen'
trailer back in January to do an
alternate cut of the film and test
screens both of them however audiences
still didn't particularly like either
cut so a very expensive round of
reshoots was scheduled for April May and
a compromised third cut based
principally on iers version merged with
the reshoots and some ideas lifted from
the trailer park cut is screened for
audiences in June with something
fundamentally the same released to
theaters in August the result is more or
less what you think it would be from
that description we're mainly going to
be focusing but not exclusively on the
film's bad editing to really get into
this first a primer when people say a
movie has bad editing they're going to
be talking mainly about two different
kinds of editing shot-to-shot
and scene to scene or momentary editing
and structural editing momentary editing
is the nitty
gritty editing what kinds of cuts are
used where they placed how far apart are
they spaced and how well is continuity
preserved does a match edit actually
work does intercut dialogue feel right
can we follow the action properly and so
on and so forth
structural editing is the bigger picture
what order are scenes in how is the
movie as a whole pasted when our
flashbacks inserted our locations in
geography properly established our
foreshadowing callbacks properly
implemented and all of that Man of Steel
is a good example for illustrating the
difference the momentary editing and Man
of Steel is generally okay the editing
problems are all structural with the
flow from scene to scene being really
poorly executed ideas and themes are
abandoned or strung out in the wrong
order and the overall package is really
poorly paced in equal measure The Last
Airbender is a great example of bad
momentary editing with lots of poorly
selected cuts bad reverse shots and just
a lot of terrible decisions all-around
Suicide Squad likewise is so full of
problems from structural to momentary
that I would seriously advise anyone
with an interest in the art of cinematic
editing do their own full autopsy to see
just how much went wrong and plain old
doesn't work
now whenever a studio starts to mellow
with a film there's an instinctive
response a desire for a clean narrative
the cast one side is the villains and
the other as either the heroes or
victims the evil greedy heartless
corporation beating up on the poor
misunderstood visionary artist now there
have been a few times in history where a
potentially great film was ruined by a
studio that either didn't get it or
maybe an executive had a personal beef
with the director or just something else
happened that led to a chain of bad
decisions most of the time though the
underlying movie wasn't that good to
begin with notoriously Sony meddled
heavily with Josh Trank's 2015 Fantastic
Four film fan 4 stick ordering a round
of heavy reshoots that as a result of
Kate Mars awful wig stand out like a
sore thumb
the problem is that if you actually look
at fan 4 stick as a whole the stuff that
wasn't reshot isn't that good either
tranqs cut of the film was likely better
in the sense that it was probably more
cohesive but it wasn't a lost
masterpiece from sony's perspective they
had a worst-case scenario on their hands
something that was neither broadly
marketable nor particularly good on its
own merits and this is the situation
that Suicide Squad was almost certainly
sitting in the unfocused production
resulting in a movie too grim and moody
for mass appeal while being too loose
and meandering to draw an audience
through critical acclaim and positive
word-of-mouth like Fanta for stick the
earlier cuts of the film were likely
more coherent but would have been paced
even worse and still plagued with
various plot incoherencies
so there's an element in Suicide Squad
it's it's a tiny thing an insignificant
thing in the scope of it all but I'm
going to start with it because it's
emblematic of the kind of problems that
the movie has as a pretty direct result
of its chaotic development there's this
really old standby rule in screenwriting
the rule of threes you set up an idea
you remind the audience then you pay it
off it's a rule because it's a really
effective way of keeping the audience
informed about smaller details that the
characters would be familiar with so
that when they come into play they don't
feel like they're coming out of nowhere
so it really stands out when Suicide
Squad manages to screw it up even though
they were sort of clearly using it all
right Captain Boomerang has this pink
unicorn it's first introduced as a gag
during his title card where it flashes
fetish pink unicorns leaving aside the
sexual implications during the gearing
up segment he pulls a pink unicorn
stuffed animal out of his duffle bag and
covertly tucks it inside his jacket so
that right there is the setup were shown
a prop and were shown exactly where it's
put inside his jacket left side it's a
very deliberate action moving forward to
the first big action scene boomerang
gets knocked around a bit fights a bit
and the stuffy flies out of his jacket
during the melee and afterwards he again
covertly stuffs it into his jacket left
side again super deliberate there's the
reminder then in the tower brawl Captain
Boomerang is wrestling with a tar
monster who stabs him right in the heart
and for a second you go oh no but being
a savvy and attentive viewer you
immediately go I'll wait the unicorn and
you pat yourself on the back as
boomerang pulls out the knife stuck in a
wad of money the unicorn incidentally is
never seen again after the reminder
now the apologetic reaction is to assume
that this is intentional that it's
deliberate misdirection a subversion of
expectations you're expecting the
unicorn but are surprised when it's not
the unicorn however if you were trying
to subvert the expectation you would
still want to show the unicorn at the
moment of subversion so what
happened well maybe the unicorn was
originally a wad of bills but one day
Jai Courtney decided a unicorn was
funnier but that already shot the office
were all a month earlier and no one
caught it in the chaos well maybe there
was a payoff for the unicorn but it hit
the cutting room floor
well maybe the unicorn was never meant
to pay off and the wad of cash was
better established but later at its bias
towards the unicorn because it's funnier
and establishing the cash hit the
cutting room floor like maybe a missed
boomerangs looting he finds the cash and
stashes it in his vest or something but
we never saw that in the finished cut
either way it's a pretty bad edit for
something really minor and it's a
microcosm of the problems with this film
how the Edit does a poor job of keeping
track of all the balls that are in the
air how it foreshadows things that never
pay off and how it's plagued with
extraneous elements that exist only is
set up for future films swinging to the
other end of the spectrum is an element
that the movie actually does establish
well and clearly and then just ruins so
the antagonist of the movie is the
enchantress an ancient witch whose
weakness is her heart
this wicker looking thing that Waller
keeps in a box strapped to a bomb so
we're told about the heart
some say the witch has a secret buried
heart whoever finds it can control the
winch then the functionality of the
heart is demonstrated
then it's reinforced its the raising of
the stakes when enchantress gets her
heart back and going into the final
fight rick flagg lays out the plan you
got a movie in flag we got to cut her
heart out and just in case you weren't
aware of the Jeopardy the visual design
of enchantress reminds you constantly by
giving her a visibly glowing green heart
this is at this point incredibly well
established it's the single best
established rule of the film's fiction
if there were anything in this movie
that you could feel 100% confident
trusting the audience to follow along
with in a chaotic moment this is it the
Enchantress's weakness is her heart and
then this happens you mess with my
friends
[Music]
watch out we can end this for our child
we can end this so all the momentum both
emotional and kinetic the flow of action
across the screen is stopped dead so
that flag can re-expand what's going on
then just to keep it awful the Edit
completely loses track of where
enchantress is she doesn't come back on
screen until the super close-up shot
that does nothing to help orient where
she is in the room
we cut before she fell down so from the
point of view of the rest of these
slo-mo shots she just kind of vanishes
and Harley who was standing right next
to her isn't anymore and just okay oh
and then the heart Harley pulls the
heart out with her hand rips it right
out full fist and then it's just poof
gone until boomerang picks it up under a
bench after everything's over
normally a detail like that wouldn't
matter except it's the object that the
Jeopardy revolves around now editing is
a process of decision making
what do you show what do you not show
and it's often a zero-sum game with huge
opportunity costs because you're working
within a relatively small chunks of time
in order to communicate everything vital
while still making the timing feel and
here's a big word
verisimilitude eNOS that doesn't mean
real that means a plausible simulation
of real you know it's fake but it feels
acceptable you can buy in you can
suspend a disbelief so that opportunity
cost they either didn't shoot or chose
to cut Enchantress falling down Harley
throwing away the heart anything that
would help keep track of the action but
they included a reacts planation of the
one thing the audience should thoroughly
understand that right there is bad
editing
all right so this one is just a
singularly awful edit aims what you met
it's not real right it's not real
there's no motion to lead into the cut
we're focused on the wrong character
leading into the cut and the crew is
already way too far into the action on
the far side of the cut in a moment
where they're trying to build up
momentum in action they end up skipping
too much time and space the difference
between the two sides of the edit are
too discontinuous making the Edit field
jarring in a moment where it should feel
fluid this is honestly the kind of edit
you'd expect to see from a mediocre film
student or well a trailer house speaking
of things that feel like they should be
cut by a trailer house the opening
seconds of a movie are so critical I
mean I shouldn't even need to explain
that there is a litany of terrible
movies out there that at least managed
to get their opening few seconds right
and Suicide Squad doesn't even manage
that the opening shots of the film live
in the void between punchy fast paced
cuts and slow deliberate cuts they don't
hang out long enough for you to really
take in what they're trying to tell you
but they're not fast enough to blur
together into a single conceptual image
this is a problem that's aggravated by
the fact that the movie throws up a lot
of hard to read text in the first few
seconds like let's look at this opening
shot this is actually an example of how
a bunch of good ideas can be layered
together to create a single bad idea
this transition is really three
different transitions that combined turn
the opening seconds into visuals soup we
transition into the shot through the
slit in the rotating DC Comics logo so
right off the bat we've got lines all
pulling our focus right to the horizon
which works with the first frames being
the dark blob of terrain in the middle
of the shot because on top of that
transition we also have a focus rack so
it actually takes a handful of frames
for things to snap into focus before
your eyes can really grab something and
then on top of that is this surreal neon
color grade which itself takes a few
more frames to transition into the awful
shades of concrete that is the film's
normal color grade so that's a really
visually busy first two seconds and in
the midst of that they toss up location
titles in the lower right and before you
have a chance to read it because your
eyes were almost certainly focused on
this tower into these two white balls as
the primary objects of interest in the
frame the camera starts flying over dark
grass so now you have black text in a
hard to read font flying over noisy dark
dark green grass and then it's gone
because we immediately cut to this now
your eyes which we're down in the lower
right trying to read the location are
going to first reset to the middle of
the frame both out of instinct and
because there's a skull and the brain is
hardwired to seek faces next priority is
all the text but first a truck drives
front of everything then soldiers walk
past the camera then you actually get a
chance to read and around the time that
you're getting frustrated by this
half-demolished word we cut into the
guard post and you've got about two
seconds to absorb any pertinent
information before we cut to inside
Deadshot cell and it was at this point I
knew I was in for an editing nightmare
there's a phenomenon in film called the
Kuleshov effect which we could talk
about in length but the underlying idea
is that more meaning is created from the
interaction of two shots than of a
single shot in isolation we can already
see this in the movie we start flying
over the water towards the compound and
then cut to the writing on the wall and
assume that this wall is a detail of the
building from the previous shot and then
we cut to the guardroom which we assume
is inside the building we were just
looking at and then it falls apart in a
very small way when we go inside the
cell this guard is sitting here watching
these monitors we're instinctively going
to follow or try to follow this person's
eye line but rather than cutting to an
angle that reflects the guards
perspective via the security cameras
we're instead much lower to the ground
looking up at Deadshot working his
punching bag it's a cut that's
technically correct in that we're moving
deeper into the facility with each cut
but it's off its the cinematic version
of putting the emphasis on the wrong
and here's the thing they use this exact
technique that I'm describing in Reverse
when the next scene with Harley ends
heck they use it again at the end of the
movie they're clearly not trying out
some methodical avant-garde style of
editing it's it's just bad
so the first 20 minutes of the film are
consumed by a bad musical montage it's
also highly redundant and full of dead
ends Suicide Squad has a big cast it's
an ensemble piece with like eight core
characters it's a lot of people to
introduce with the added complexity of
explaining what their comic-book gimmick
is and maneuvering them into place
within the plot further complicated by
the fact that the underlying conceit of
the film is that the cast are all
antisocial villains working for the
government
more or less against their will that's a
lot to set up now they introduce almost
everyone with capsule size flashbacks
narrated by Waller which is a pretty bad
way of introducing your protagonists
Suicide Squad like ogres has layers
except in this case it's layers of bad
awkward decisions so the bad musical
montage is bad because it's cut like a
movie trailer it's all sizzle at a time
when the film should be busy
establishing themes and conflict as with
many things we've already addressed what
they're doing here isn't 100% wrong it's
not an idea that's rotten to the core
it's just incredibly inefficient cutting
your opening for sizzle isn't a bad idea
until it's gone on for 30 minutes and
you're just starting to get around to
the actual plot the original movie would
have been much longer and much slower
paced but by cutting the introductions
for sizzle trying to turn it all into a
high-energy peppy montage that
inefficiency stands out because they
need to keep coming back to
introductions over and over again to the
point that halfway through the movie
they're just finishing introducing the
core characters this is katana she's got
my back
she cut all you and have with one sword
stroke just like mowing the lawn
I would advise not getting killed by her
her sword traps the souls of its victims
so we're a five to eight minutes scene
with dead shot could easily fit in all
the pertinent details plus some trying
to do it all in poppy trailer style
means that they need to keep coming back
which in turn means there's no time for
anyone else putting the story in a place
where the core conceit doesn't work
because they were only able to squeeze
in negotiations with Deadshot and no one
else and I haven't even addressed the
soundtrack yet this trailer style peppy
montage relies heavily on pop music in
the bluntest way possible it's a prison
in Louisiana House of the Rising Sun by
the animals harley isn't your plaything
you don't own me by Leslie Gore Amanda
Waller is bad and she's going to
introduce a bunch of devils sympathy for
the devil Harley's a super freak so
let's just play super freak an Aussie
who does dirty deeds dirty deeds done
dirt cheap
oh the habló lost control and he's
slipping into darkness Jesus this writes
itself Killer Croc is unfortunate so hey
fortunate son Will Smith is black and he
shaved his head black skinhead they're
assembling like an army seven nation
army they're flying in a helicopter
spirit in the sky like any one of these
on its own would be blunt but
appropriate however when it's your one
trick that you use over and over again
oh yeah and that wasn't even all of them
in fact from the opening shot to the
title card its end to end they've
already used three different songs
before the title even comes up Baz
Luhrmann has more restraint than this
on repeat viewings the first half of
this movie becomes almost unbearable
because you already know how it ends so
you spend the first 50 minutes sitting
through numerous threads that you know
don't matter one of the most obvious is
this guy Griggs Griggs is one of the
head guards at Belle Reve and the first
three minutes of the movie aren't spent
introducing us to Deadshot and Harley
they're spent showing us just how awful
Griggs is not Belle Reve not being
locked up in general Griggs in specific
now if they wanted him to be a bit of
comic relief that's fine in fact if
there's one thing this movie actually
really needed it was a lot more
antagonistic rapport between the squad
and the rest of the world so our first
bit is this back and forth between
Griggs and Deadshot which could build up
to that kind of a beat Griggs ribs
Deadshot Deadshot ribs back they both
laugh call each other an [ __ ]
walk away instead Griggs has Deadshot
beat with batons by a dozen guards next
up is Harley and it's the same deal this
could be banter antagonistic banter but
still banter instead the scene cuts to a
flashback of Griggs outright abusing and
humiliating her these are the opening
scenes of the movie this is the pace and
tone being set they are clearly setting
up a direct obvious antagonism between
the squad and Griggs through that first
40 minutes they keep reinforcing that
antagonism and upping the stakes
foreshadowing future resolution to the
point that Harley outright tells Griggs
what
by that what do you mean by that get off
Carly what do you mean by that and
that's the last we see of Griggs he
doesn't even show up at the end of the
movie when the squatter back in prison
now there's a couple different problems
going on here the first is a scripting
problem Griggs was over developed in the
first half of the movie and then dropped
the second is an editing problem because
of that lack of payoff Griggs should
have been significantly trimmed down
well there's another scripting problem
which is that the staff at Belle Reve
are so consistently absurdly abusive to
the squad that it strains any credulity
when it comes to the plan of recruiting
them to do missions I mean these aren't
people who are going to be cooperative
and useful because you've treated them
like absolute garbage in turn this
doesn't make Waller look like a master
tactician someone who is as she claims
the best at getting people to act
against their own self-interest it it
just makes her look like an idiot
psychotic anti-social freaks it makes no
sense
so a twist is a surprise subversion of
the audience's expectation but in order
for a twist to work expectations need to
be established before they can be
subverted so there's a twist in the
middle of the movie where boomerang
tricks Slipknot into trying to escape
and flag blows up the bomb in Slipknot
snek the twist doesn't work though
because Slipknot was clearly introduced
as disposable everyone else in the squad
is introduced with the heavy-handed
soundtrack choices name cards logos and
a bio from Waller it's bad but it still
sets a precedent
so when Slipknot steps out of an SUV and
gets a one-line introduction here comes
Slipknot the man can climb anything
wonderful it's a pretty clear tell to
the audience that he's not important and
you shouldn't care so when he dies it
doesn't mean anything
it's who cares you were told not to care
I suppose we should take some time to
talk about the actual antagonist of the
film enchantress whose possessing the
body of June moon who's in love with
rick flagg now there's a lot of problems
here and this is going back to the
underdeveloped script I mean the biggest
being that she's just an absurdly
powerful opponent for a team that should
be busy doing like a heist or something
I mean this speaks to the basic fiction
of the movie that Waller is putting
together a task force because what if
what if Superman had decided to fly down
rip off the roof of the White House and
grab the President of the United States
right out of the Oval Office who would
have stopped him but if that's the case
then why is Captain Boomerang here or
Harley Quinn or Killer Croc or Slipknot
like sure Killer Croc is a big guy and
he's scary and he can take a punch but
at the end of the day he's a linebacker
with a skin condition he's not
superhumanly strong he's just regular
strong boomerang isn't even special he's
just a thief with a gimmick Harley
Harley is pure liability anyway okay so
enchantress is introduced as part of the
team and then her powers demonstrate
to the brass of the Pentagon and then
she more or less immediately betrays
Waller and releases her brother in
Midway City as part of her plan to
escape but at the same time in between
those points and this is speaking
directly to the poor structure there's
the demonstration at the Pentagon
followed by a second montage of
introductions to the squad
none of which move the plot forward at
all because the parts where Waller and
Flagg tried to negotiate with Croc
boomerang and Harley we're all cut and
Diablo just tells them to piss off so
the only one they actually get to
negotiate with is Deadshot but that
doesn't go anywhere either because they
then immediately ignore the entire
conversation so okay the only one of
these that tells us anything new is the
conversation with Diablo which builds
his character a bit shows the audience
that he's basically at peace with his
punishment so that's useful character
development even if the structure of the
scene does nothing to progress the movie
itself also keeping in mind that the
actual plot hasn't started yet oh they
also bring June moon to the prison and
highlight her presence with a closeup
reaction shot as they arrive but she
never interacts with any of the rest of
the squad so when she goes rogue no one
on the team except flag has any
emotional stake in the situation anyway
all of these largely pointless meetings
culminate and flag telling Waller that
it's a dumb plan because they're mostly
worthless and their hostility just makes
them a liability in any operation where
loyalty would be an asset which is every
operation ever the scene ends with this
ominous line where flag asks Waller what
she's really up to and Waller tells him
it's a need-to-know and all you need to
know is you work for me now that's
actually important because it tells the
audience that she is in fact up to
something it's foreshadowing a reveal
Waller has secret plans that are at odds
with the interests of either her bosses
or the squad or both don't worry though
we don't find out what they are because
she doesn't actually have secret plans
at least not as far as this movie is
concerned so yeah then there's a couple
scenes with Joker and he starts to
orchestrate Harley's breakout and then
we finally get the
plot rolling with enchantress releasing
her brother in Midway city and oh yeah
her brother so if this feels like it
comes out of left field a half hour into
the movie that's because it more or less
the movie now prior to this
Enchantress's brother Incubus is only
mentioned in her title card which were
all written by trailer park for comedy
and freeze-frame Easter eggs for the
home audience like flags lists his golf
handicap the point is these are jokes
the next glancing reference is
enchantress looking at this page during
the demonstration of the Pentagon except
when the camera is looking at this page
Waller is talking about enchantress and
telling the room everything we know
about her is in your briefing packs so
the relevance of this shot that it
represents some potential jeopardy
really isn't clear until you're already
familiar with the plot the visual
difference between what we're being
shown and what we've been shown in the
past is nominal no one's mentioned that
there's a second statue that poses a
similar risk and Waller is summing up
information that we're already familiar
with all of the film's signifiers are
telling us that this is old information
we don't need to care so when
enchantress is snooping around while his
apartment and finds her brother statue
sitting on the self like a tchotchke it
comes out of nowhere and this whole
betrayal culminates in one of the best
worst moments in the movie so from the
audience's perspective Incubus is
wrecking Midway city and we know that
Flagg knows that enchantress was up to
no good
he doesn't know exactly what she did but
presumably he can put two and two
together
well he clearly doesn't and he doesn't
even bother to tell his boss that maybe
we can't trust the witch right now
because she might be responsible but
anyway putting that aside flag and Moon
are suddenly in the subway under Incubus
and he braids her into transforming and
Clyde talk to me what's going on down
there
Valka say it again
okay so this is an important moment this
is the moment that flag realizes he's
made a big mistake and it's the moment
that really kicks the plot into high
gear and instead of using that to build
tension hard cuts and we learned what
happened over the radio a masterpiece of
bad decisions coming back to the subject
of twists this movie actually has a
twist I guess but it's bad surprise
after the squad finally gets assembled
at the midpoint of the movie Waller
gives them their mission which is rescue
HVT one which I mean wasn't the whole
point of Task Force X to throw them at
metahumans that are wrecking stuff what
if Superman had decided to fly down rip
off the roof of the White House and grab
the President of the United States right
out of the Oval Office Midway city's
under attack its non-human entity I
think you know what to do sir activate
Task Force X get Amanda Waller and her
whole circus on scene ASAP okay so
that's confusing in its own right but
they eventually get to HV t1 and it
turns out it's Waller she was in Midway
City this whole time so this is a twist
that isn't actually a twist because it's
pointless
nothing changes by hiding that
information nothing changes when you
find out that Waller is the target while
her being in the city doesn't make sense
in the first place and and then Waller
kills her staff and says what they will
include for any of this anything well
then then who were they
what's going on why are you here
why were they here what are you actually
doing this is one of those moments that
exists to try and surprise the audience
but it just raises more questions than
it could ever answer and they're bad
questions it's not enticing questions
it's questions of confusion
there's there's a lot more that I
haven't even touched on like how the
Joker's plot cul-de-sac is used how
Harley story was gutted because it was
an endless downer that still didn't pay
off how the wrap-up doesn't even mention
that Diablo sacrificed himself for the
squad but instead I'll just rattle those
off in list form to give you an idea
that they're there this is I think a
pretty good vertical slice of the kind
of editing problems that plague Suicide
Squad from beginning to end
[Music]
you